Killer Elite based on a true story
Dolphin Tale based on a true story
Moneyball based on a true story
abduction not at all based on a true
story but Taylor Lautner is not a good
actor and that is a true story
abduction subduction stars Taylor
Lautner from Twilight he's doing this
high school project with this hot
neighbor chick and then he sees on a
website that's one of those rendered
photos works like oh this kid may look
like this now it's a missing kid he
looks just like him and then secrets
unfold now I'm gonna start this by
touching on the statement I made in the
intro of this video Taylor Lautner is
not a good actor he's just not it's
almost like Taylor Lautner's either so
stoic he has no emotion or he has too
much like he's all like or she says
something that he's like we can't
there's no time man it's just like that
I think Taylor Lautner would be a good
stuntman like oh okay yeah I'll jump off
buildings for the actors and so that'd
be fun he's a strong dude he's got the
physique for it Taylor Lautner just be a
stuntman it'll be fun for us to not have
to watch your movies the thing about
this movies it tries to be so cool and
tries to be so special like oh this is a
really cool premise we're gonna pull it
off like this and it is kind of an
interesting premise but it doesn't have
any good acting to back it up it's a
high school version of enemy of the
state
just watch enemy of the state it's like
a million times more relevant than
abduction all the good actors in this
movie aren't big parts in the movie
Alfred Molina is in it he's a good actor
jason isaacs isn't it this guy was one
of my favorite actors in like 2002 when
he was really just climbing like dude
you're the bad guy in the patriot you
are badass and now he's a small part in
abduction it's like Lucius Malfoy I
realized that Harry Potter is over now
but you don't have to backslide so much
the neighbor chick is hot I don't know
who she is but she's hot
jason isaacs even says him he's like oh
yeah I never choose a kid she's kind of
hot now Maria Bello Xena she looks good
for as old as she is I was never dumb
enough to get married I would hope my
wife would look like Maria Bello and she
was her age I know the Taylor Lautner is
a wrestler in high school and he's
athletic and all that but how does he
get so agile that he's jumping off of
like fences and beams and he's all
acting like a spy like he's had this
training all his life he hasn't jason
isaacs would spar with him I get that so
he knows how to fight that doesn't mean
you know how to do half the other crap
you've been doing genetic memory maybe I
don't know I didn't care about the
villain I didn't care about the good
guys I mean some of the spy stuff had a
good concept behind it I've seen it done
a hundred times better in a hundred
other things in a story arc in a movie
like this the main guy in the main girl
they're gonna be alone about halfway
through the movie and they're gonna
start talking about stuff and relating
to each other we get that right how do
they do it in this movie by having her
be like remember that time in junior
high why didn't you ask me out at the
beginning
the year at that point I was like high
school is such a serious thing these
problems matter I can't sing for
but that's the song that came to my mind
and it fit perfectly this is enemy of
the state in high school on the CW
network why didn't you ask me out at the
beginning of the year and not even as
good as that in the end this movie would
be a good time if you're looking for a
high school spy movie and you're drunk
and now there's a party and we're spies
so your favorite spy movie villain
what's your favorite comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more